[Music]
[Applause]
he's the popular peter king football
morning and america columnist and of
course contributor to football night in
america day one of free agency who stood
out good or bad pete
i think the los angeles chargers have
virtually remade their team in the last
seven days signing mike williams
to a big deal so they keep
uh you know justin herbert's really
become his favorite receiver
uh then they go out and trade for khalil
mack who
none of us really know how much he has
left
but clearly at age 31 he becomes the
piece
that kind of von miller became for aaron
donald
in with the rams and then they go out
and they get the best corner on the
market uh jc jackson has got more
interceptions than anybody in the last
four years
in the nfl and
i think and they get sebastian joseph
data as a space eater in the middle of
their defensive line
what the charger said in essence was
what and what brandon staley told me at
the scouting combine
we are going to become a deep team
and that's what they are becoming right
now
when he was the defensive coordinator of
the rams two years ago
he had a lot more depth on his side of
the ball
and that is what in my opinion this
early portion of free agency in the mac
trade does to the chargers they've been
the most aggressive and most impressive
team so far i thought the jags made some
moves the bengals made some moves short
up the offensive line is there
maybe that uh that big weapon still out
there that you could uh that you think
some teams are going to be fighting over
i don't think so dan i think that
this is one of the this is this is
probably the sanest
first 24 hours
of the free agent signing period
that i've seen in a long time
because there are still some very good
players out there there's a quarterback
darius williams who a year ago
was probably a top five quarter in the
nfl he's still very highly regarded he's
young
he's waiting to strike it rich
so there are players who the nfl is
saying we like you
but we're not going to pay a ransom for
you there are very few ransoms this year
as opposed to last year in the first 24
hours
do you like what the steelers did or the
commanders did at quarterback
more
mike florio had a great line about
carson wentz is that finally he
has been kicked out of the house you
know he
he came into the nfl and there was you
know his two most important guys
were doug peterson
and frank wright well doug peterson uh
you know benched him
and the eagles divorced him and then he
went to uh his safe haven frank reich
well after one year that's over now he
goes to where nobody knows him
and he he basically has got to convince
everybody hey i am still the quarterback
you saw in 2017. before i suffered this
knee injury
and i think mentally this is the best
thing for him he's been thrown out by
the two people who like him have liked
him the most in the nfl
now
i probably like washington a little bit
more than pittsburgh because we still
are not convinced at all that mitchell
trubisky is a good nfl quarterback
and
he benefited
i mean dan he benefited greatly
by not playing last year
so think about that he i mean he played
for brian dable
uh and sean mcdermott but he never
played so the point is he looked great
in practice so what what does that mean
we still don't know the thing i like
about this from the steelers point of
view is let's say he has two great years
the next two years and proves that he's
the successor to ben roethlisberger
his contract maxes out at 27 million
over two years he's still going to be
incredibly cheap so the way i look at
this is i think the steelers
did a smart thing
i just still have no idea if mitchell
trubisky's really any good
tom brady retiring or unretiring more
surprising to you
oh
probably about equal because i think we
all knew that there was a good chance he
was going to come back and now that we
saw how he came back
you know dan he had to come back if he
was going to come back
he had to come back by sunday
now with some hindsight we understand
he wanted ryan jensen
badly
i think if you look at the guys who he
really wants back
it's ryan jensen rob gronkowski
um those to me chris god
one and one a and then comes chris
godwin
but
ryan jensen is the most important to him
because he's already lost
um you know a pro bowl guard in ali
marpad who is not coming back he's
retired and then he knew they were going
to lose alex kappa to free agency
he could not come back to a totally
denuded
interior offensive line
and when when you look at what ryan
jensen meant to him
he's got a little
s
streak to him
you know where
you know he's not a friendly guy out
there that's what brady wants when he's
in the middle of these
you know these little battles he's he's
having and so
i think it was really important that he
gets him back so
tom brady sunday told the bucks you
better get ryan jensen back and then he
told ryan jensen look i'm fighting for
you don't agree anywhere else before
you know you get absolutely as far down
the road as you can with the bucks
sunday night at 11 o'clock
his agent mike mccartney uh you know
tweets that this deal is done that was
crucial
but i think in general
i don't think this is that complicated
dan jim gray told me on sunday night
essentially
tom brady doesn't want to be watching tv
in september and look at the tv and said
i'm as good or better than any of these
guys
michael jordan still watches nba games
peter and probably thinks the same thing
hey joe theismann
thought it until maybe four or five
years ago yeah so
you're right about that i'm sure michael
j hey look michael jordan could could go
out right now on a given night and score
20.
i'm we're all convinced of that but the
question is
what what do you what what does that
mean the difference is that tom brady
last year had his most
productive year
uh you know statistically
since the randy moss here in 2007. he
did that at 44. dan
one of the other guys who knows tom
brady very well told me yesterday
said here's the other thing about brady
that people have to realize
nothing
hurts
he's not in any pain
last year a year ago he had to have that
surgery
with neil alatos to repair his knee
and so he had to go through a bunch of
rehab in the off season right now no
surgery no rehab arm doesn't hurt
shoulder doesn't hurt knee doesn't hurt
he's fine
so
you know he still really loves doing
this more than anything else as long as
his family's okay with it
and they appear to be very okay with it
why not
he's peter king the uh must read column
every monday morning football morning in
america what do you make of the aaron
rodgers contract details there that uh
uh
150 million over the next three years
were the first two years fully
guaranteed
you know
i think what it said to me was
so
it's going to be very hard for aaron
rodgers to walk away after one year
clearly
and
when i read that and look at that
i look and say okay
mentally aaron rodgers says i'm playing
the next two years
that's what i think and
the only thing about this dan that
that to me is a little bit troubling for
the packers
is that
they have to sign
uh devonta adams
and
you know i don't take what he said
yesterday which is i'm not playing for
the franchise tag
i don't take that
all that seriously
but i think what the packers probably
should do
is sign devonta adams to four to a four
year or five year contract
but with
these kind of dead years at the end the
phony years where you know
there's a good chance that's going to be
it
when i look and see
when i look at c roger's contract the
one thing i say is
he's on that team for the next two years
devante adams has his godfather for the
next two years so he's going to make a
lot of money the next two years and are
the packers going to be
okay enough
by pushing a lot of money into the
future
uh to make sure that they have aaron
rodgers and devonte adams through the
last game of 2023.
what are the browns doing by
talking to interviewing flirting with
deshawn watson
i mean
i think they sit here right now and
think
at best there's a 50 50 chance that
baker mayfield's our guy long term
maybe some people in the organization
think it's 60 40 that a healthy baker
mayfield is going to be
good enough for them to contend
to go deep into the playoffs next year
but
probably what they're thinking is here's
a guy who if we can withstand
the
the storm
of
uh everything that's going to come at
deshaun watson
in these civil suits for the next year
or so
if we can withstand that if we can
withstand
a lot of our customers being supremely
ticked off
that the the billboard of our franchise
is going to be a guy who currently is
being accused by 22 women
of sexual impropriety
dan i just think you know everybody is
saying oh let's go get to sean watson i
mean
this is not gone away criminally it's
gone away
for the time being probably forever but
how about how about in the court of
public opinion
and in the court of civil
legalities
he really still this is not over and so
i just think
you have to have a certain belief
in desean watson i talked to one general
manager over the weekend
not cleveland but talked to one general
manager over the weekend
who asked me which tells me everything
you need to know
and i don't think he's gonna end up
going to this team but
but uh
how many of those 22 cases do you think
go forward and are serious
so
you know it's clear
that nfl decision makers want this to go
away
and believe that at one point it will go
away and we'll see if it does
thank you pete great to talk to you
again have a great week
all right thank you dan that's peter
king football morning in america must
read column by pete